they are some of the world's most
endangered animals and at this zoo in
south devon conservation work is taking
a futuristic turn
genetic samples are being taken from
animals that are neutered or die
in a bid to save them from extinction
for a lot of species
time is running out and we do you know
we work tirelessly to conserve animals
all the time is what we do um but there
are a lot of species for whom the
challenges they face in the wild are
particularly pressing
and as i said it acts as a safeguard for
these pieces so we can we can conserve
their genetic material for future use
samples from these mandrels have already
been donated
more than 200 miles away in the
shropshire countryside
the science is happening
this is where an animal's tissue is
stored frozen in a living state at minus
196 degrees celsius ready to be used if
a species is on the brink of extinction
charity nature's safe has so far cryo
preserved genetic samples of 82 species
if we've got that unique dna we can use
that in many many different different
attributes so in theory in years to come
we can turn that skin sample
into a sperm and an egg which is quite
incredible but the science is moving at
such a rate if we don't freeze it now
we have lost those species forever
with 40 000 species at risk of
extinction the charity says they need to
act quickly we're at the cliff edge of
losing so many species on a daily basis
we have nowhere else to go so we've got
to do it here and now
whatever it takes
being on the technology side we have to
use those tools to be able to stop them
from disappearing
the urgency of climate threats and the
destruction of natural habitats are
leading conservationists to find new
ways of ensuring these animals aren't
lost forever
dan whitehead sky news in devon